people in bungie have been on edge for
days now
that's after the armed movement calling
itself patriots coalition for change
threatened to match the city and disrupt
the vote the group's leaders didn't want
an election
but a transitional government and the
full implementation of a peace deal
signed between 14 armed groups and the
government in 2019
despite the uncertainty polling stations
opened on time
and voting in the capital was fairly
smooth
am here to vote for peace i have heard
about problems in other parts of the
country
but i had to do my bit president faustin
ashan stuart
has been urging people to help security
forces stop the rebels
the national army backed by u.n
peacekeepers
random forces russian military
instructors and private security
contractors
are all on the ground france also has a
military presence
in the central african republic
every five years central africans freely
choose their leader
the institutions responsible for this
mission are the ane
and the constitutional court and the
date set is the 27th
this is why all central africans come to
vote and i myself came to fulfill my
civic duty
there are 17 presidential candidates on
the ballot paper
but any say georges tologele is said to
be president odera's
main challenger he says he's worried
that people in some villages and towns
in the provinces
were unable to vote because of the
security situation
unfortunately i have the impression that
more than half of the country did not
vote
which is what we feared when we asked
for the conditions to be set for every
citizen to be able to exercise their
right to vote
i have the impression that many have
been deprived of the right to vote and
that is a pity
more troops have been deployed to
troubled areas and the capital bongi
we've been speaking to people in
different neighborhoods in the city just
trying to get
a sense of the voting pattern many have
told us that they have voted and they
are voting for peace
others say they are worried about the
security situation in parts of the
country
ben adam says he has voted in two
elections
but is not interested this time i was
born in this country
but i feel i have been marginalized as a
muslim what's the point of voting again
some political analysts are concerned
that an extremely low voter turnout
could affect the credibility of the
polls government officials we talked to
say
they are confident that won't be the
case final results are expected in the
coming days
catherine soy al jazeera bongi